[Music]
so i don't know if anybody uh
watches the great british bake off but
you know they always have uh someone
going on and saying i've practiced this
at home
a bunch of times and i've never made it
in the time limit i've practiced this
talk three times and i've never made it
in 20 minutes
so buckle in so
i'm going to be talking about stochastic
block models with r
and how they can be used to do
statistically rigorous clustering
but with a lens of rigorous code and i
don't know if you read the actual title
on the conference page but in my
title with 11 words in it i made three
typos
so i'm getting there
so this talk is going to be laid out
kind of roughly into this
organization of what what i'm selling uh
kind of every talk is selling something
the why
the process and the product
so quickly just about me a little bit
can help to orient you a little bit
previously i've done some software
engineering roles
primarily working with javascript and i
had the pleasure of working at the new
york times and the graphics department
for a while building data visualizations
um and currently i'm a phd candidate at
vanderbilt biostatistics
and i focus on visualization and
unsupervised learning
and in the future i'm currently looking
for data science positions
i'm going to graduate in about four
months so if that interests you at all
you should probably leave right now so i
don't ruin everything
after this okay so getting into what i'm
selling
uh because like i said every talk is
selling something and it's nice if
they're a little bit more upfront about
what that is
um so i'm selling two things really
first
is just that a thing uh it's this
package sbmr that i've been making
that performs uncertainty aware
unsupervised clustering of graph data
we'll get into a little bit of that
jargon a little bit
but more importantly i'm selling an idea
and that idea
is that building an r package alongside
a research project can serve to
strengthen both the package and the
research
so let's start with why but first
we're going to do a jargon break a lot
of times you sit in talks especially in
modeling talks and people
throw out phrases at you that you don't
know and then you stop listening and
that's no fun
so first i'm going to define bi and poly
apartheid networks and networks in
general
because i'm going to mention them a
little bit so bipartite networks or
polypartite networks are networks that
have
nodes of multiple distinct types where
connections can't form between nodes of
the same type
so in this example we have various
pollinators and various flowers
and you can draw an edge between a
pollinator and a flower
based on you know if that thing so if
that pollinator pollinates that flower
so butterflies pollinate lilies and
clovers
but you could never have a connection
from butterfly to moth because that
doesn't really make sense and then
also stochastic block model this is a
phrase i'm going to use a bunch and i'm
also going to abbreviate it as
sbm and this is simply just a network
model
that clusters nodes into blocks of nodes
and these nodes are grouped by the
similarity of their edges so in this
example we have this red cluster right
here
and it's characterized by connections
within itself so you know all of the
nodes tend to connect to nodes that are
in the same cluster the same thing goes
for the blue and that
all that needs to be known about a given
node is what block it is
in and what the connection propensities
of that block
are so because i
exist in academia right now and if you
don't show an equation in your talk
people assume that you don't know what
you're talking about so this is just the
actual
equation that governs this whole
stochastic block model
and it's it's quite simple even though
there's a lot of greek greek letters
going on
but basically you just need to know the
data which in this case is a and that
comes in the form of edges between nodes
which node each group or each what group
each node belongs to and then a matrix
of the expected edge counts between
those groups which i was talking about
earlier is the propensity
and then you might notice if you're
familiar with uh some statistical
formulas that this looks very familiar
and that's because
it's simply a poisson model so poisson
models model counts
based on a parameter that is the average
expected number of counts
and so in this case the number of edges
from a node to another node
is governed by this poisson distribution
where the propensity or lambda value
is what is learned in the model
so really why i showed this equation is
that a few years ago
i got the poisson distribution tattooed
on my arm
and i did that because i really just
liked it i thought it was a cool elegant
distribution
and little did i know that i would be
spending the next couple years of my
life
intimately familiar and sort of hating
the equation
so why stochastic block models
so in my research we lurk a lot with
electronic health records or ehr data
and so with this type of data questions
that often arise are things like who are
these people similar to and why so we
might go to a
collaborator and they would have that
question of you know i'm interested in
patients with type 2 diabetes can you
show me other patients that are similar
to them
and tell me why they're similar so the
first thing that i tried was
deep learning methods so these worked
well
but they had a couple problems and one
is that they lacked interpretability
you know it could tell you that these
you know nodes were similar to each
other but it wouldn't tell you why it
said that
you know you can get that out of the
model but it's a little bit hard
um and it needed specialization for
these networks that have multipartite
structure
and then also we wanted a method that
acknowledges the limitations of the data
so
statisticians were very interested in
uncertainty
and neural networks again there are kind
of ways that you can get uncertainty out
of them but they are not
fundamentally built with that idea in
mind
so next is why would i write a package
to do this
and so there's a package in python
called graph tool and it fits stochastic
block models
but there's a few issues with why we
didn't use it one is that
my lab that i work in uses r exclusively
so every time i would show them python
code people's eyes would glaze over
we're also quite focused on uncertainty
and
graph tool is great but it doesn't focus
quite on uncertainty
as heavily as we would like we also
needed to tweak the underlying methods
to optimize it for these bipartite
networks and i wanted to present at our
studio conference and i couldn't do that
if i wrote a python package
so we'll get into the process now
so with every r package and really every
kind of research project that someone
does you kind of got to get to the
starting line and honestly that's
the hardest part most of the time and so
for this project there were kind of two
things we had to do
and one was look into possible graph
libraries so we decided you know we
wanted to use
r to do this graph manipulation so we
looked at you know
the elephant in the room is i graph and
igraph is a great
package however much like graph tool it
does a lot more than what we needed it
to
and i don't know if you've ever tried to
install a package that depends on igraph
but it is a
pain and also we wanted to add these
kind of computationally heavy steps
something we'll illustrate later and we
had to do that in r
by virtue of wrapping a package and that
kind of brought everything to a halt
and if you're more interested in kind of
this trade-off of
you know adding a dependency versus
writing stuff from scratch i really
encourage you to look at jim hester's it
depends talk from last year's r studio
where he kind of talks about
how big of a difference taking away one
dependency can make in the uptake of
your package in terms of you know
does it take five hours to download or
does it take five seconds
so after that we decided that we were
going to use rcpp
and rcpp as you might know is a kind of
a nice interface between r and c
plus plus code and it really just lets
you write c
plus plus code to do what you want and
then you can wire it up to r extremely
easily
and so this low level interface kind of
allowed us to get really close to the
metal
and keep it nice and memory efficient we
didn't want to keep
you know pull around a bunch of extra
data with our
model such that we were wasting a lot of
bits
and we also wanted to make sure our
processing was nice and efficient we
didn't want to you know waste
excess flops on things that weren't
necessary for what we were doing
so once you've kind of gotten a package
started the next step
and you know in research the next step
is doing tests
and so this kind of i think about this
in two ways so
from one we come from the software side
of things and software side of things
this comes in the form of unit tests
it's a unit test of these nice toy
examples that you kind of break the
problem down as simple as possible
you try to probe you know the limits of
the problem find the edge cases
and make sure that your software behaves
as you think it should
and so this can benefit uh the
statistics side of things by building
strong foundations for larger models if
you're really
sure that the model works in these kind
of minimal examples
you're going to be confident about it
scaling up and then it also
builds intuition about behavior so you
know kind of
with these uh you know graph based
models there's a lot of intuition that
goes on behind it and when you kind of
code those minimal examples you can gain
that intuition pretty well
and then from the other side when you do
a statistics methods project
a lot of times you have to build you
really should be building
doing simulated data and so
this can actually help the software side
of things i think quite well because
when you have simulated data it's
stochastic by definition and it's
going to find your edge cases right you
will never be able to fully probe kind
of the limits
of your functions with just unit tests
but stochastic data if there's a bug to
be found it will be found in
you know one of the thousand times that
you simulate data this happened many
many times um and it also gives you an
idea of real world performance so you
don't kind of get
sucked down a rabbit hole of thinking
your stuff works really well uh when you
have maybe an o of n squared operation
hidden somewhere that doesn't show up
until you start using big data
so kind of carrying on with the idea of
speed
the next step a lot of times is kind of
speeding stuff up this is more of a
software side of things
but one thing that you'll quickly learn
if you start writing a package to do
modeling is that the
exact equations that you read in a paper
or whatever are not going to be
efficient
and so the example in this package is
that we have this
this is the entropy of the model which
is essentially that's the negative log
likelihood if you're familiar with those
terms
basically we want this number to be as
small as possible
and one of the things that we do is we
move a node to another group and we test
how much this value changes
and if you do this whole thing it's a
very computationally expensive
task but you might notice if you kind of
dig into it and tear the equation apart
you know different parts of it don't
actually change and so you don't need to
calculate them
we have this divide by two here because
we're double counting using this
uh formula so we can really optimize the
equation and that
by by really digging into this we
actually have to
think about what's going on a little bit
more deep than you might necessarily do
if you're just sitting
there writing one off r scripts or
writing math on a page
so kind of taking a step back also for
the test
side of things this documentation serves
as a
documentation can serve as a test in a
way too um so
as you write these as you do this uh
research
uh and you're constantly updating your
documentation over that process
uh keeps you focused on the big picture
and so this is nice because you don't
like i said before you don't want to
you know stick get stuck right in the
unit test working little toy examples
open it up to the real world and then
you start having problems where anytime
you run it with something over 100 nodes
it takes a million years to run and it
sorts it can serve as an informal sniff
test for results so
this picture on the right is an example
of i was you know working with some data
and it kept on having these really big
drops and i was like what is what is
going on
and it was actually dropping into
negative values which is something that
shouldn't be possible
and by digging into that all my tests
were passing all of the different tests
you know all the behavior that i was
thinking about was working
but i actually found a bug in the logic
of the code from looking at this and i
wouldn't have caught that if i wasn't
constantly updating
the documentation and looking at how
things were changing
so another mildly selfish part of this
thing is writing vignettes and i think
about this right in the context of
publishing
and so as a statistician or as an r
developer
uh one of the things that you really
want is for people to use your stuff
right that's how you
get tenure that's how you know you get
recognition in your field
and if no one knows how to use what
you're giving no one's going to use it
right and so vignettes are a really
great way to do that kind of a nice
real world example of using your package
and then one of the nice things about
this is that for people if you're like
me and you don't actually like sitting
down and writing academic papers
this can trick you into uh writing a lot
and so this kind of right here is an
example of this is a single vignette
from the package
and you know when my advisor says nick
are you writing i get to show him that i
have this nice long vignette and i say
of course i've been writing
so now moving on to the kind of last
part which is the actual product that
this whole process has been leading up
to
and so quickly taking a step back to
reorient ourselves
uh what exactly is sbmr and that's a
tentative name for the package it
probably will change it's not very
creative
um but it's a native r package kind of
right it uses c
plus plus code but thanks to rcpp that's
essentially native at this point
and it fits stochastic block models and
its primary focus is investigating the
uncertainty of the found structure
by sampling from the bayesian posterior
so if you're familiar with bayesian
models you can get uncertainty by
looking at the
posterior distribution that's how we get
uncertainty in this clustering
and it provides a growing list of
visualizations to communicate the
results
so this is the link to the package down
site for it
it's not exactly ready for prime time
yet but if you want to go use it there's
a good amount of documentation written
and please report all the bugs that you
will find
so with any package or any kind of
method research
product there's you know you need to
know what you
need to do to use it and so in this
package
you need really i think a class of two
things two classes of things for what
you need
one is data so you need data that can be
represented as nodes and edges between
those nodes
also known as graph data one of the
examples that we use it for
is patients with diagnoses so you have a
patient as a node
and they're connected to diagnoses as
another node
another example that we've used it for
is genotype
for people so you have a person and a
genotype uh
a more classic example is like social
relationships and networks of you know
friends on different social networks
we don't currently support non-discrete
edges and that's just because as you saw
the
distribution that we're using is the
poisson distribution which is a discrete
distribution
there are ways to extend it to
non-discrete edges but we have not
gotten there yet
but those would be examples like
correlation networks where every every
node is connected to each other just by
varying amounts
and you also need kind of a mentality
right there's a lot of different ways to
do clustering
unsupervised learning so kind of to use
this method you're going to want to have
an interest in how and why your data
cluster together
this is kind of the nice thing about
stochastic block models is they're very
transparent in why you're clustering so
any given cluster is entirely
characterized by its vector of
propensity to be connected to another
cluster
and so if you have five clusters every
cluster is characterized entirely by a
length five vector that says how
likely it is to be connected any given
node in one of the clusters is to be
connected to the other
clusters and you need a desire to
understand how stable your clusters are
so if you just wanted to you know fit a
stochastic block model and you didn't
care
about using r you could use graph tool
currently there are a lot more features
there
but what we focus on especially is
looking at the stability of these
clusters
so now with the few remaining minutes
that i have i'm going to give a quick
demo of kind of the workflow
as you run through the package so
first thing you can do is simulate a
network and i'm going to reload this
page just because
this is an interactive network and i
feel like it's more interesting to see
the nodes
move and it'll distract you from what
i'm saying
so we're going to simulate a pretty
dense network with three clusters of
nodes
and 40 nodes per cluster and so we have
a function built into the package called
sim
basic block network and we just give it
the
various values there's a lot more
customization you can do
right now i'm just keeping it at this
default simple example
and as you'll see this is a very dense
network right we have a lot of edges
and that's actually one of the harder
types of networks to cluster because
you know there's a lot of competing
information it has to do a lot of
sorting to figure out what's going on
and as you see in this force directed
network there's no clear structure in
the data you know there might be a
little bit denser region of blue
blue nodes in the center but if someone
were to say you know can you cluster
this
by eye it would be pretty hard to do but
we know that there are three clusters
because we simulated three clusters
so the first thing that you want to do
whenever you're doing bayesian sampling
is
if you're going to sample from a
posterior you want to get as close to
the optimal starting point as possible
and this is because
when the posterior sampling you could
spend a lot of time kind of getting to
equilibrium
and so you know you might be familiar
with the concept of burning in
a chain which is where you kind of let
it run for a while until it finds its
natural resting point and then
then you start sampling but that's kind
of an inexact science
and so we have an algorithm built into
the package that does agglomerative
merging so it basically takes every node
starts it in its own cluster
and then slowly merges those clusters
together
one by one until you have one node and
it records the model fit so in this
entropy value and so higher value is
a worse fit and so what we're really
looking for here
is kind of the point where clusters true
clusters start being merged together
because the model says i have to
you know take these three clusters and
merge them into two so it had to kind of
merge two clusters that were not able to
be merged in reality
and so ideally there will be a sharp
kind of decrease
it will increase in model penalty for
that
for that uh change and so we have this
uh heuristic
for detecting that point uh which we
call the delta ratio it's something that
we've developed it's not
particularly important but it uh we can
see that right here
we've very clearly picked out this uh
point of three clusters which is what we
know i drew a line here to say you know
we know that there are three clusters
how does it tell us
and so very clearly the model has said i
think that there are three clusters in
your data
and so let me choose that and so we can
do a sanity check because we know what
actually generated the data
and so conveniently we actually
perfectly separated our clusters right
so this is the
simulated block of the node and this is
the inferred block and so what we see is
that every single
inferred block perfectly corresponds to
the data generating block
and this algorithm honestly works
incredibly well it's it's uh
you could really if you wanted to just
do all of your inference in this model
without going to the bayesian values and
you you do pretty well it does
surprisingly well
so once we have that kind of
equilibriated
uh posterior situation we can do
mcmc sweeps and so we can just pipe
our model object to this function mcmc
sweep
tell it how many sweeps we want to do we
give it an epsilon value and epsilon in
this case is an ergodicity parameter
so it kind of uh influences how random
your choices of different nodes are so
you know when a node is
sitting and being checked in a sweep how
likely it is to be you know given to
just a random group rather than one that
follows the data
um and we also have this interesting uh
value called track pairs here that we'll
get into in two seconds but what we can
see
is that we have a very stable chain and
honestly that's because it's perfectly
equilibriated right we know exactly
where it is and it perfectly fit there
we get a little bit of variation as we
go over our sweeps as the number of
nodes moved but everything is working
pretty well
so you know that's fine but what we're
interested in is looking at the
uncertainty in this clustering
and so when we do that track pairs
option what it does is it keeps track
internally at every single sweep it says
you know these two nodes are they in the
same cluster internally
and then as we do our sweeps we just
keep tallying up that
value and that gives us this kind of
consensus matrix
and that will tell us so right blue is
you know 100 of the time we were in the
same group and so we can aggregate
all of these mcmc sweeps to get an idea
of the kind of stability of our network
and so this is an easy way to see it
however you know this is nice and uh got
little nice triangles here and that's
because we know the true structure
so what if we don't know the true
structure so we can't sort it because if
we didn't have this sorted it would look
kind of
you know it'd be hard to tell unless we
knew the true sorting of the network
so we have a new thing that we're
calling consensus snee
so you might be familiar with t sne uh
which is t distributed stochastic and
neighbor embedding
we're calling this consensus knee it's a
totally made-up name that i just did
today
but it's basically taking these
propensities and building a network
between
nodes where the node is connected to
another node
if it is you know follows some threshold
of connection and so what we can see is
with our data and i'll refresh this
again
it perfectly separates itself into the
component clusters that we generated
um and what you'll see is in you know
less certain models there might be some
connections between so you get the
hierarchical structure
um without having to you know figure out
how to sort your heat map
so i have very little time left but the
future plans
we're going to focus a little bit more
on node level uncertainty to allow us to
try to find
you know outlier nodes values that don't
really fit the generating distribution
that we've inferred and we're also going
to just put a lot more visualizations
i've been working on this product for a
long time and i have lots of
visualization ideas and i want to
kind of start pumping them out now that
we've got the fundamental
kernel going on and just a quick
thanks so to my advisor yaman joo at
vanderbilt
lab biostatistician siwei zhang who's
been working with me on this
and the other lab members for their
thoughtful comments during the whole
process
i'm supported by the vanderbilt
biostatistics development grant
and most importantly my cat has been
very helpful all the days that i banged
my head against the wall
while i couldn't figure out some bug he
was there and i guess
my wife was there too to help me out so
thank you very much